ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
VINDICATED AFTER NEARLY A YEAR
AND A HALF.
TODAY THE SUPREME COURT UPHELD
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THE
PRESIDENT'S TRAVEL BAN.
THE LEFT REACTED AND IT'S
TYPICALLY RESTRAINED WAY AND
THEN THE REPUBLIC TWEETED, IF IT
WASN'T CLEAR, IT SHOULD BE NOW.
HE JOINS US NOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU HAD A BAND THAT DIDN'T
COUNTRIES LIKE NORTH KOREA.
CAN WE JUST SAY NOW THAT WAS
>> YOU KNOW TUCKER I WAS ON YOUR
SHOW EXACTLY ONE YEAR AGO TODAY
TO ARGUE ABOUT THIS WITH YOU.
ONE YEAR AGO THE SUPREME COURT
ISSUED ITS DECISION THAT
OVERTURNED THE HALT ON THE BAN.
NOW THE SUPREME COURT HAS MADE
ITS FINAL RULING ON THE THIRD
BAND.
THAT THIRD BAND IS DIFFERENT
BUT IN THE END, THERE ARE MANY
WHO STILL BELIEVE THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE BAN WAS TO BAN
MUSLIMS FROM COMING TO THE
COUNTRY.
AND THERE IS SOME SUPPORT FOR
STILL REALLY BAD POLICY FOR THE
COUNTRY.
TOOK HOLD OF AND A VERY THIN
MAJORITY, 5-FOUR, USED TO RULE
IN FAVOR OF THE BAN AND SUPPORT
THE BAND.
>> LOTS OF MUSLIMS WHO WERE NOT
A SECURITY THREAT AND WE FOUND
SOME MUSLIMS WHO HAVE ACTUALLY
ENGAGED IN TERRORIST ACTS HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: IT SO HOW WOULD WE
KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE, IF IN AN
IMMIGRANT IS FROM AFGHANISTAN,
SOMALIA, SYRIA?
DO WE TRUST THOSE GOVERNMENTS TO
KEEP CLOSE TRACK OF THE RECORDS
SO WHY WOULD WE TAKE ANY RISK IF
WE EVER CAN'T KNOW OR WILL KNOW
WHO THEY ARE?
>> OBVIOUSLY THE ADMINISTRATION
THINKS IT KNOWS AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S TAKEN THE TIME TO BAN
PEOPLE FROM CERTAIN COUNTRIES.
>> BUT DON'T WE KNOW, TO A
ARE, AND TO PASS ON ANY
APPLICABLE OR RELEVANT RECORDS
ABOUT YOU?
THAT'S A DIFFERENT DYSFUNCTIONAL
PLACE.
SAME I WOULD ARGUE SYRIA UNDER
CONDITIONS OF CIVIL WAR RIGHT
NOW.
SO WHO WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT?
DO WE TRUST THE GOVERNOR OF
SOMALIA TO TELL US THE TRUTH?
>> Tucker: WHILE THEY MAY, BUT
SOMALIA TO THE VET FOR US, THE
PEOPLE OF SOMALIA WHO COME HERE?
IS OBVIOUSLY CRAZY.
>> WHAT WE HAVE TO TRUST
SOMEBODY, RIGHT?
SO WHEN DHS, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT -- WHEN THEY
DID A REVIEW THEY CONCLUDED
ACTUALLY, THIS ADMINISTRATION
WARRANTED IT NOT TO BE IN THE
BAND.
THEN IT WAS PUT BACK IN THE BAND
THEN IT WAS PUT BACK IN THE BAN
BAND.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD I TRUST
SOME BUREAUCRAT AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WITH MY
COUNTRY, AND MY CHILDREN?
LIKE, HOW WOULD WE KNOW?
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS, DON'T WORRY
ABOUT IT.
WHY SHOULDN'T I LAUGH AT THEM
WHEN THEY SAY SOMETHING SO
SELF-EVIDENTLY STUPID AND
DISHONEST TO ME?
>> A COUPLE OF REASONS.
FIRST OF ALL AMERICANS DESERVE
TO BE SECURE.
BUT WITH RESPECT TO SOMALIA, ANY
REVIEW PROCESS.
THOSE REVIEW PROCESSES GENERALLY
WORK.
SIMILE IN GOVERNMENT.
THEY DO AN INTERVIEW.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE -- THIS IS SO
STUPID.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY ON THE
GROUND IN SOMALIA.
HOW MANY STATE DEPARTMENT
EMPLOYEES ARE VETTING THE MANY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF SOMALI
REFUGEES WHO HAVE COME TO THIS
COUNTRY?
HOW MANY ARE THERE IN SOMALIA?
HONESTLY, DO WE HAVE THOUSANDS
DJIBOUTI, THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE
U.S. EMBASSY, AND DO THE PROCESS
THERE.
>> BUT WE CAN'T BET ANY OF IT
BECAUSE SOMALIA IS NOT
FUNCTIONING COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT FINE.
AND WE KNOW THAT NOW, BECAUSE WE
HAVE -- ACTUALLY THEY DON'T SHOW
THAT AT ALL.
>> >> NO AMERICAN HAS BEEN KILE
>> >> NO AMERICAN HAS BEEN KILD
BY A SIMILE THAT CAME TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AND HOW MUCH MONEY TO SOMALI
TERROR GROUPS AL-SHABAAB HAS
FLOWN FROM MINNEAPOLIS THE LAST
THREE YEARS?
WE ARE OUT OF TIME,